put on your blindfolds
[Music]
players
if you feel my touch on your shoulder
then you are a traitor
foreign
[Music]
I'm so excited I know I can do this I
can be the final player in this game and
that is the goal
[Music]
this is all I wanted
I'm going to stab in murder and Destroy
so many people I'm going to make
everyone question every single thing
coming out of their mouth
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I am so excited that I'm a Trader but it
is going to become much more difficult
to stay under the radar and not do
something that can tip off a faithful
I have selected the traitors
and the course of the game is now set
you may remove your blindfolds
[Music]
my job now is to go unidentified and the
only way that I can do that is to
persuade people I mean I could never be
anything a tree you think I could be a
traitor
see that was good right
I'm a faithful so one I'm gonna be
looking for inconsistencies in stories
but I'm also going to be looking at who
is throwing everything at the wall to
get the scent off of them I'm looking
for those small cracks and that'll help
me pinpoint the Traders
the next time we meet here at the round
table faithful you will have the chance
to try and banish a traitor from the
game
remember faithful if you can oust all of
the traitors those of you who are left
will share up to a quarter of a million
dollars
oh
one teeny weenie final little thing
tonight traitors you will discover each
other's identities and faithful one of
you will be murdered
I'll see you shortly for our first
mission
ciao
Geraldine just looked so nervous every
time I looked at her she couldn't make
eye contact with me
she'd look down she looked away
I think I'm gonna be very good at this
game because I love judging people
there's not much else to do here but
judge people and I can't really turn it
off do I trust these people I don't
trust anyone
foreign
[Music]